[Music]
all right Tamika Tomika where you're
from originally where'd you grow up
well I've lived a lot for different
places I was in placement for a long
time so like over in LA and Long Beach
and like sorry California yeah the high
desert too you know and tell me about
your family hit both your parents as a
kid um nah I just met my dad like six
months ago or something like that and my
mom being dead since I was like six
you lost your mom earlier yeah shivery
death like 20 years who raised you um my
first like my auntie and then I went
back into the system so yeah I wasn't
group homes and foster homes and stuff
how would you describe your childhood I
mean it was different like you know I'd
know parish it
yes whatever any abuse or anything
traumatic ever no I just was hmm oh no
you know different I guess
okay and you you went on your own at
what age 18
well yeah 18 like but I got pregnant you
know so I was like you know I was still
in a foster home and you know I was like
damn about to have a baby and [ __ ] so I
tried to like you know do [ __ ] different
I just you're right you know but that
shouldn't last for long
you know gonna have two more kids and
it's just too much it it was hectic like
so you have three children are you
raising
you live at that did you still see them
yes you do but you know like his mom she
don't like me so it'll be cool like that
you know they'd be shipping stuff and
I'd be like you know maybe I'm ready to
fight you know because it's wrong like
yeah so no no I just don't I don't got I
don't got it like a little job or
nothing [ __ ] like what the [ __ ] that's
not supposed to do you know know so I
just was like okay my homegirl is
telling me some [ __ ] like you could just
give money like this you know I'm not my
[ __ ] [ __ ] it
there's being money you know so I just
been getting money ever since like it's
all c-note you know oh no I will be
willing to work and stuff but like she
don't happen like that you know
especially like the people like you know
me and [ __ ] so did you finish high
school
no cuz I mean I got pregnant I tried to
go you know but the end it got hectic
there's nothing
why don't I watch my baby and you know
then I was pregnant too I already had a
baby I was pregnant you know so I just
you know stop why did you started
working you start working the street at
what age when I was 18 eating more do
you work with a pimper on your own
oh my oh my homegirl told me about it
like
and I just I never always try to stay
away from pimps you're not kidding out
before but you know [ __ ] that she was
that she was crazy like I think that was
really out here like kidnapping business
and [ __ ]
oh no that [ __ ] was so crazy she was
scary but I don't know I still like I
still gotta get my anything I just try
to be a little bit more careful of it
yeah it's a dangerous way to make money
right yeah those were like hey oh [ __ ]
we won't be going to work or guns and
stuff so like that's dangerous way to
make a livin to you know have you had
some bad experiences um besides getting
kidnapped no not really I kind of just
like I don't know I think I'll just be
like I'll be like two seconds from
dangerous it like I'll be finding out
like oh I could have just been right
there and you know to know for something
to help him but I didn't seen a lot of
[ __ ] though oh [ __ ]
initiatives crazy oh you're like man you
don't even know cuz you know to see it
and to live it is two different things
you know like what's the craziest thing
you've seen
the crazy thing well you've avoided the
terrible stuff but I'm sure you've
probably seen some stuff yeah like I've
avoided a lot like I was like what my
friend one time she was like well let's
go with this with this guy or whatever
and I was like I don't know I'm not
going with that [ __ ] you
shouldn't go either like you know and
like oh no she got she got like stabbed
up and stuff like oh no a gang [ __ ] and
I was like damn like I felt bad but I
was like ah toughest [ __ ] not to go
like that's crazy people is crazy you
know and I was scared though because I
could have been right there I was just
right there with her you know I she was
all I was like Manish is crazy I was
like damn you know cuz if I win who
knows you know you have to use your
intuition yeah yeah it's me
better how many how many customers do
you just say no no thank you
yeah like so like lately like a lot of
people has been crazy out here
oh noes I was trying to like about the
internet you know I'm sorry I've been
trying to like work off the internet no
like all Facebook or whatever have you
been arrested before yeah I've been
arrested here in Las Vegas gang of times
in Las Vegas so you go to Vegas
sometimes - yeah you make more money
there yeah but I mean I make a lot of
money so what are you making tonight
like anywhere from 8 to 12 mm-hmm and
you work what hours roughly really like
the night like cuz I'm I like the night
so you'll start at what time I like 7:00
until what time until 5:00
and the guys you'll pick up will be
drunk or they'll be I really like to do
it with drunk people you know but I mean
unless just like you know this is dry or
something but your customers are white
black Mexican it all matters just
everything else alone another one
holder your kids well this is a sign off
your hand will be seven and my baby will
be six that's a tender yeah eventually
there they'll be old enough to figure
out what mom's doing and hopefully like
automate it buddy
and I got it you have made it out yeah
and I got it you know st. got it know
that our drugs are part of the picture
for you know I tried to like pop pills
before but Joe's not a smoke weed though
a lot of weight and you've not worked
with pimps no I'll just
mm-hmm must try to stay away from things
I don't kid like especially I thought
I'm kidding that love [ __ ] as crazy [ __ ]
that right
this is lifestyle get you depressed
sometimes you get down that's fine I
drink a lot you drink a lot
hmm you have to be drinking too in order
to even do this are you saving money I'm
sorry you spend it as fast as you make
it uh I've been working on it I've
talked with a lot of the girls that do
this and they say that they're addicted
to the lifestyle I would have said I'm
addicted but I would say like it's a
little bit more than recreation
what do you think most people don't
understand about girls that do this for
a living I mean because they don't they
don't know like what it's like to have
like that's a like absolutely nothing
like would she like oh what I'm gonna do
messy like nothing like you know I'm
saying like and I'm gonna have nothing
like don't even think about it cuz you
got nothing you know I'm saying and
people don't know that [ __ ] they don't
know what that [ __ ] for like so they
have a lot of lots to say on how they
feel you know I should be or she should
be or whoever should be when they don't
even know cuz if they knew they wouldn't
even say that like you know I know they
wouldn't say that cuz I wouldn't say
that you know and I know and you and
your backs against the wall yeah you
know that's crazy but I mean you have no
other options it becomes an option it
was the best time of your life
um I think well my oldest I was born
yeah I was happy how was our happy yeah
what was what was the worst time mmm
probably like now burger yep how do you
sum 26 26
you ever stand back and just look at
your life and go man this is this is
nuts
yeah like I say what I planning for it
to be did you envision a different life
for yourself are you always new like
where I was gonna be you know when I was
younger as a kid like oh no I just own
it I wanted to be like a journalist and
[ __ ] all kind of [ __ ] was like it should
when I grew up in reality was her oh it
was like man you know it was for real
yeah honey you're still very young -
yeah
you find this lifestyle gets in the way
of romantic relationships for you
yeah I just gave up on lots of
relationships because they don't even
make sense to me anymore if your mom had
not passed away at such a young age you
think that might have steered unit
are you finding the limit the the line
that you'll draw as to what you'll do
and what you won't do changing is as the
years go by you know I'm pretty far
along without stand by what you do
and where do you see your life going
from here I mean you're 26 you said you
see getting out as a possibility I hope
so yeah what do you think would help a
girl in your situation to make a change
it's a lot
it's the ability I think really that's
the main thing
do you have dreams of anything that you
ever like fantasize about some some life
that you could somehow find
trying not to do it you know but [ __ ] oh
no it just helps out to be heavy I one
day
all right Tamika well thank you so much
for talking with me and good luck with
wherever you go from here you're still
very young
thank you thank you
you